au modem on encourage l'engagement
citoyen et on place ce citoyen au centre
du problème
[Musique]
politique je m'appelle Floriant Mazet
j'ai 26 ans j'ai grandi à Levalois peré
en Île-de-France et je suis le président
des Jeunes Démocrates d'Île-de-France
alors j'ai eu un baccalauréat économie
sociale puis après j'ai fait des études
à l'université Paris Nanterre j'ai
ensuite fait un Master de Sciences
politiqu ce qui m'a permis de rencontrer
Isabelle Floren ancienne députée
maintenant sénatrice des auè j'ai la
chance d'être son assistant
parlementaire à la fin de mes études
puis au début de mon parcours
professionnel et ensuite maintenant je
travaille au conseil régional
d'île-de-fance auprès des élus de la
majorité présidentielle j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer le modem lors des
élections municipales de 2020 où je
participais à une liste citoyenne dans
ma ville le modem et des représentants
du MoDem y étai à force de militer côte
à côte de passer du temps à défendre des
valeurs et un projet pour ma ville je me
suis naturellement rapproché du
mouvement et maintenant depuis 2020 bien
je continue à m'engager de plus en plus
parce que je crois aux valeurs du
Mouvement Démocrate et à l'engagement
citoyen au modem on encourage
l'engagement citoyen et on place ce
citoyen au centre du problème politique
on part de ses besoins de ses
préoccupations pour porter nos
politiques publiques pour apporter des
réponses et pour construire ensemble
l'intérêt général pour conclure je vous
présente mes meilleurs vœ pour cette
année 2024 et je vous encourage à vous
engager que ce soit dans une association
un syndicat un parti politique
l'engagement est essentiel dans notre
République l'engagement est essentiel
pour notre société c'est l'engagement
qui nous permet de construire ensemble
un avenir
meilleur